another day another rail strike and in
Stoke on Trent more last minute
disruption to plans
we knew there was a strat but we didn't
really plan
it has we should have but we didn't so
we are stopped here for an hour waiting
to go
it's crazy like we had to literally Rush
down here just to make a particular
train hoping we even get to make that
particular train I feel like train
striking to get better right it's just
made everything a bit more stressful
than usual
um going out to have a nice day and
we're just worried about getting back
nationally fewer than half of train
Services were running on Saturday as
workers walked out again in some sectors
industrial action has been paused nurses
are assessing a pay offer and Junior
doctors and teaching unions are in talks
with the Westminster government but the
UK's biggest rail Union says their
dispute is different they're not saying
to doctors you've got to take less sick
pay or lower pensions in fact they're
boosting doctors pensions it seems from
the headlines I've seen they're saying
to us in the railway Railway pension
scheme that they're going to increase
the contributions and lower the benefits
so we call it Rings attached it's the
strings that are attached to this deal
that really concern our people
well it's at Heathrow Airport are due to
strike at Easter and more than a
thousand passport stuff are due to walk
out from across the UK for five weeks
starting in April
it's worrying news for those who have
holidays booked
for my 30th birthday we're meant to be
flying out of Heathrow on the third
and flying from Manchester Heathrow
Heathrow to JFK it could be ruined with
I've had birthdays before but three
birthdays ruined because of covid and
covered lockdowns and this was a meant
to be a special one for 30th and it's a
bit distressing that we don't know
what's going to happen
what became a winter of discontent for
those affected by strike action looks
like turning into a spring and maybe
even a summer of disruption for some
Travelers
Lisa Dao Sky News Stoke-on-Trent